bonjour à toutes et tous je voulais
m'adresser à vous depuis usine kolmi
hopen à saint barthélemy d'anjou et vous
dire d'afir t d'être là dans cette usine
aux côtés des dirigeants et de ses
salariés
nous avons un combat contre le virus a
mené des soignants qui sont au front
chaque jour et je pense à eux et nous
sommes à leurs côtés
et évidemment des soignants qui sont à
protéger à équiper et un défi que nous
connaissons depuis le début sur lequel
le premier ministre ministre de la santé
plusieurs membres du gouvernement sont
revenus ces derniers jours qui est celui
des équipements des matières premières
de notre capacité donc à les aider ce
sont d'abord les masques les masques
chirurgicaux ou ffp2 donc ces masques de
protection pour les soignants nous le
savons les difficultés que nous avons
rencontrées sont liés à la très forte
augmentation de la consommation que nous
avons de ces masques nous sommes passés
de 4 millions par semaine à 40 millions
par semaine pour les soignants à peu
près et cela a mis une forte tension
avec un stock existant le premier
ministre et les ministres ils sont
revenus des quelques jours en début de
crise qui était de 140 millions de
masques disponibles et avec au fond une
certitude qui avait présidé aux choix
passé qui était que ces masques on
pouvait les importer très facilement
qu'ils étaient produits en très grande
quantité à l'autre bout du monde souvent
en chine parfois ailleurs et qu'il n'y
avait pas lieu de stocker massivement
des milliards et des milliards de
masques
le monde a changé depuis quelques
semaines a créé une tension inédite sur
les marchés mondiaux et des difficultés
profondes
le gouvernement a édicté une doctrine
pour ne jamais être en rupture et
pouvoir toujours équipé les soignants
qui sont les plus exposés au virus
les déstockages se font chaque semaine
et nous continuons d'être vigilant mais
pour faire face à la crise à ces 40
millions de masques dont nous avons
besoin par semaine au moins
plusieurs décisions ont été prises
d'abord celle d'importer massivement et
vite
plus d'un milliard de masques venant de
chine et les commandes sont en train
d'arriver avec des commandes
supplémentaires qui sont d'ores et déjà
passé et je veux ici aussi remercié les
collectivités locales les entreprises
qui ont durant cette période donnée les
masques qu'elle avait mais ont aussi été
chercher sur les marchés mondiaux des
grandes quantités de masques pour les
mettre à disposition de nos soignants
mais il nous faut aussi est à mes yeux
aujourd'hui avant toute chose produire
davantage en france sur notre sol
produire parce que cette crise nous
enseigne que sur certains biens certains
produits certains matériaux le caractère
stratégique impose d'avoir une
souveraineté européenne
produire plus sur le sol national pour
réduire notre dépendance et donc nous
équiper dans la durée nous avons quatre
acteurs historiques en france qui
produisent des masques chirurgicaux et
ffp2 entre autre code ni open
ici près d'angers est le plus important
et représente plus des trois quarts de
la production française
un effort extraordinaire a été fait ces
dernières semaines avec l'aide des
services de l'état de la chambre de
commerce d'industrie d'une mobilisation
exceptionnelle de l'entreprise
de nombreux partenaires qui a permis
d'augmenter les effectifs de 50% de
faire tourner l'usiné 7 jours sur 7 24
heures sur 24 de commander de nouvelles
machines qui sont en train d'arriver
la production en quelques semaines ici à
d'ores et déjà doublé et nous allons
aller plus loin tous ensemble avant la
crise nous produisions en france 3,3
millions de masques par semaine fin
avril nous serons à plus de 10 millions
nous aurons plus que triplé en quelques
semaines et nous continuerons cet effort
pour continuer la multiplication de nos
capacités de production et je veux que
d'ici la fin de l'année nous ayons
obtenue
justement cette indépendance pleine et
entière en parallèle de nouveaux acteurs
faurecia charger michelin intermarché
plusieurs autres se mobilisent aussi
pour produire des masques dans la
période et nous aurons ainsi la capacité
à produire en france d'ici fin avril
environ 15 millions de masques par
semaine c'est donc un travail de
reconquête sur une production nationale
d'une avancée qui n'est possible aussi
que parce que nous avons gardé lé
expertise et je veux féliciter cette
entreprise qui a su maintenir cette
compétence en france contre vents et
marées qui a réussi à maintenir aussi
une filière et achète à 100 % des
produits européens aux trois quarts des
produits français et dont les machines
mem sont françaises nous allons en
parallèle de ce travail qui est
nécessaire pour équiper nos soignants
dans les meilleurs délais et pour
dépendre de moins en moins de nos
importations continuer à produire plus
de masques parce que je pense aussi à
toutes celles et ceux qui sont exposés
aux services à domicile à nos
transporteurs à nos pompiers à nos
forces de l'ordre à nos caissiers et
caissières au guichetier à toutes les
professions qui sont aujourd'hui exposés
qui je le sais ont souvent une angoisse
et attendent des masques
il est aujourd'hui impossible de leur
promettre ces masques ffp2 ou
chirurgicaux ils sont réservés aux
soignants et nous devons avant tout
sécuriser notre capacité à leur donner
à mesure que nous montrons j'espère que
nous pourrons l'élargir mais nous avons
d'autres catégories de masques
différents qui sont homologués 85
prototypes ont été validés durant les
derniers jours et nous sommes en train
de monter aussi notre capacité de
production nationale pour fournir
progressivement des masques à toutes ces
professions
d'ici trois à quatre semaines nous
aurons la capacité de produire un
million de masques jour sur ces
différentes catégories
le gouvernement reviendra là aussi sur
les différentes catégories d'emplois
cette indispensable
les masques c'est une bataille
essentielle le gouvernement a fait toute
la transparence est mobilisée depuis le
premier jour et nous continuons
d'avancer
nous avons ensuite un autre sujet
critique les respirateurs vous le savez
nous en avons besoin
avec des services d'urgence de
réanimation qui sont de plus en plus
mobilisés avec tant de nos concitoyens
qui sont en détresse respiratoire aiguë
et qui ont besoin de ces respirateur là
aussi nous avons évidemment passer de
nombreuses commandes
nous importons nous avons la chance
d'avoir plusieurs producteurs européens
et en particulier un grand producteur
français qui est airliquide que je veux
remercier depuis pour sa mobilisation
depuis le premier jour air liquide
fournit ses respirateur de différentes
catégories
depuis son usine d'anthony j'ai une
pensée toute particulière pour les
citoyens de cette ville je le sais
endeuillé ces derniers jours une
initiative a été monté durant ces
derniers jours et autour d'air liquide
un consortium industriel français vient
de se constituer qui réunit air liquide
schneider electric
valeo et psa ce consortium va permettre
de produire d'ici mi mai dix mille
respirateur des respirateurs lourds
comme des respirateurs plus léger les
respirateurs lourds qui sont
particulièrement attendus feront l'objet
de premières livraisons dans les
prochains jours environ 250 dans les
huit prochains jours puis ce consortium
montra justement montera en volume et en
production pour pouvoir fournir 10 mille
respirateur français d'ici mi mai enfin
ce sont les produits dont nous avons
besoin
le gel hydro alcoolique qui fait partie
aujourd'hui de notre quotidien depuis
que les gestes barrière se sont
justement mis en place nous avons
décupler notre production passant de 40
mille litres jour à 500 mille litres
jour
je veux remercier là aussi l'ensemble de
nos industriels de nos fabricants mais
aussi des pharmaciens des établissements
de santé à qui nous avons donné la
possibilité de produire qui se sont
mobilisés d'une manière
exceptionnel durant cette période pour
produire et apporter ces jeunes nous
avons aussi besoin de médicaments et de
matériel je ne rentrerai pas ici dans le
détail le ministre de la santé l'a fait
de tout seringue de curare parfois aussi
de principes actifs
il y a nombreux matériels médicaux de
tests évidemment qui sont aujourd'hui
soumises à une très forte tension sur le
marché mondial compte tenu de la crise
que vivent tous les pays sur ses
médicaments
notre stratégie est simple nous sommes
en train de passer massivement et nous
le faisons depuis plusieurs semaines
nous passons massivement des commandes
tout ce qui est produits ou peut être
produit en france les et nous mentons là
aussi en volume tout ce qu'il est en
européen est aussi poussé en volume pour
sécuriser les apports afin de financer
tout ça le gouvernement apporte une
contribution une dotation spécifique à
santé publique france 2 4 milliards
d'euros qui permettra de passer ses
commandes en médicaments respirateurs et
masque c'est évidemment une contribution
exceptionnelle qui montre la
mobilisation aussi de l'état et de ses
financements
derrière cela vous l'avez compris pour
mener ce combat contre le virus dans un
contexte où toutes les certitudes sont
balayées tout revu et la tension sur le
marché mondial extrême
nous avons bien sûr une stratégie de
commandes d'importation mais notre
priorité aujourd'hui est de produire
davantage en france est de produire
davantage en europe
partout nous avons des sites de
production français
deux montées en volume d'embauchés de
pousser davantage nos capacités et de
créer aussi de nouvelles capacités de
production
je veux aussi remercier nos dirigeants
d'entreprise nos entrepreneurs de france
les salariés les ouvriers de nos grands
groupes de notre pays de nos pme qui
sont mobilisés dans cette bataille qui
sont cette deuxième ligne dont j'ai
parlé la semaine dernière la première
ligne et celle des soignants la deuxième
ce sont ces femmes et ces hommes qui
permette au pays de continuer à tourner
et qui permettent de l'équipe et je veux
les remercier et nous les avons applaudi
tout à l'heure parce qu'ils sont là au
travail avec courage ils sont là alors
que parfois leurs familles vivent dans
l'angoissé
ils sont là alors que leurs enfants sont
parfois je le sais à la maison et qu'il
faut trouver une bonne organisation et
qui sont accompagnés par leur entreprise
c'est un engagement exceptionnel que
nous soutenons le jour d'après ne
ressemblera pas au jour d'avant nous
devons rebâtir notre souveraineté
nationale et européenne
nous avons commencé avant crise et vous
m'avez souvent entendu vous en parler
nous avons passé des réformes qui
permettent à notre pays d'être plus
compétitifs mais il nous faut retrouver
la force morale et la volonté pour
produire davantage en france et
retrouver cette indépendance
c'est ce que nous commençons de fer avec
force courage sur les produits de
première nécessité pour cette crise
c'est ce que nous continuerons à faire
le jour d'après souveraineté
souveraineté et solidarité car cela ne
serait pas possible sans l'engagement de
femmes et d'hommes qui ne comptent pas
leurs heures et qui avec courage sont là
pour faire avancer le pays
je les en remercie très profondément je
vous remercie
c'est cette france unie à laquelle je
crois c'est cette france unie dont nous
avons aujourd'hui ici le visage mais qui
partout en france se déploie avec force
et qui nous permettra de gagner contre
cet ennemi invisible car il n'est pas un
récit merci à toutes et tous vive la
république et vive la france
merci à vous mesdames messieurs
la deuxième ligue
l'économie du pays vous avez promis une
prime d'heures seulement
oui les tendres alors pour être clair la
prime ce sont les entrepreneurs les
entreprises qui les versent l'état le
gouvernement peut l'accompagner en
décidant de supprimer les cotisations et
impôts qui normalement accompagnent ces
dispositifs le gouvernement à l'occasion
d'annoncer à l'issue du conseil des
ministres de demain les modalités en
effet de la prime exceptionnelle que je
souhaite voir verser au salarié
nous accompagnons en effet l'ensemble du
tissu économique et alors que nous
sommes en fin de mois il est important
de revenir sur chacun de ces leviers
nous avons décidé d report exceptionnel
de charge aussi de loyer et de déchéance
qui était extrêmement importante et
angoissante
nous avons mis en place un dispositif de
chômage partiel en nous inspirant nos
voisins mais en étant plus généreux que
dont le gouvernement a précisé les
dispositifs mais qui est aujourd'hui le
dispositif de chômage partiel le plus
généreux d'europe et qui permet d'éviter
le licenciement dans ces périodes de
crise pourquoi nous le faisons parce que
nous avons constaté lorsque nous avons
vécu la crise économique il y a dix ans
que la france avait à ce moment-là
détruit beaucoup d'emplois et donc de
compétences donc reports de charges
déchéance noyer pour les entreprises
chômage partiel pour protéger les
salariés les compétences dans
l'entreprise et maintenir au maximum
l'emploi
et puis ce fonds solidarité sur lequel
le ministre de l'économie des finances
et ministre de l'action des comptes
publics sont revenus que je veux très
simple et qui permettra d'accompagner
tous les petits entrepreneurs de france
indépendants artisans commerçants tpe et
qui fait que quand on a perdu dès le
mois de mars mais aussi en avril plus de
50% de son chiffre d'affaires ou quand
on fait partie des catégories de métiers
qui ont été fermés par le gouvernement
eh bien on a une compensation par ce
fonds de solidarité qui est d'environ
1500 euros et qui permet là aussi de
tenir
et puis il y aura cette prime
exceptionnelle j'ai demandé au
gouvernement de travailler ajustements
l'accompagnement de tous les
fonctionnaires qui
sont mobilisés et donc de pouvoir mieux
valoriser les heures travaillées
particulier en lait en les payant comme
les heures supplémentaires ni un
dispositif justement de primes et je
souhaite que nous puissions aussi
accompagner le secteur privé c'est
chaque entreprise qui décide de la prime
qu'il veut verser mais que nous
puissions rester répliqué ce que nous
avions fait l'année dernière avec une
prime exceptionnelle les modalités en
seront décrites par le gouvernement
demain alors il est trop tôt pour le
dire d'abord quand on est dans une
stratégie de réduction des contacts
physiques avec les contraintes que nous
avons mise au pays le souhait est que
justement on ne soient pas placés dans
cette situation là mais il nous faudra
préparer l'après et il nous faut aussi
pouvoir répondre à la fois cette demande
de protection parfois qui répond à
langoat mais qui peut répondre aussi à
des choix très cohérent il est
aujourd'hui trop tôt pour décliner une
doctrine mais je ne veux pas subir et
donc ma priorité c'est de produire des
masques pour les soignants et pour
toutes les personnes qui sont exposées
parce que quand je dis les soignants on
a aussi et c'est ce que nous avons
déployés les personnes qui sont dans les
ehpad les personnes qui sont souffrantes
personnes qui sont dans le médico social
ou dans le social ac il ya eu des
livraisons exceptionnelles mais en plus
petite quantité de masques mais le
gouvernement a fait livrer dans les
ehpad chez auprès des associations qui
accompagnent justement les personnes les
plus démunies et les plus isolés
certains de ces masques non en plus
petites quantités donc là nous devons
être en situation que jamais les
personnels soignants qui sont au contact
ne m'en de masques
donc nous sommes en train de corriger
des situations qui fait qu'on aviez une
une contrainte qui étaient liés aux
stocks trop faible par rapport à la
rapidité de la propagation du virus de
cet afflux de personnes malades et les
tensions sur le marché mondial donc ma
priorité c'est ça c'est la stratégie que
le gouvernement vous a décrites c'est ce
que je viens de vous annoncer en termes
de capacité à produire quand nous aurons
touché les commandes
parce que moi je ne crois qu'aux
importations qui sont arrivés sur le sol
français
quand nous aurons touché des commandes
quand nous aurons monter notre capacité
à produire d'ici à quelques jours
quelques semaines nous pourrons alors
avoir une planification de ce qu'on peut
donner c'est à dire comment on élargit
justement les masques qui sont donnés
chirurgicaux et ffp2 au personnel
soignant plus largement et peut-être
progressivement aussi plus largement aux
personnels médico social du monde social
nous aurons à ce moment là un choix à
faire qui est de savoir si on peut sur
cette catégorie de masques dans la phase
de crise élargir à d'autres professions
notre conviction c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce
sont plutôt des masques qui ne se relève
pas des masques chirurgicaux et ffp2
mais qui sont ces masques d'autres
catégories sur lesquels nous travaillons
d homologation d'ores et déjà été donné
les capacités sont lancés dont les
propriétés sont un peu différentes mais
qui correspondent aux besoins qui puisse
être donnée à toutes ces professions et
donc je voulais dit ici à 3 4 semaines
nous aurons devront avoir une capacité
de production d'environ 1 million masque
jours à ce moment là nous aurons nous
allons affiner une doctrine dans les
prochains jours de déploiement justement
de ces masques pour prioriser les
catégories qui sont les plus exposés je
parlais de nos forces de l'ordre je
parlais des sapeurs pompiers je parlais
aussi tout à l'heure un des salariés le
disait très justement des transporteurs
et progressivement l'élargira parce que
à la fois il ya un besoin et il ya une
demande sociale qui est là je le
constate comme vous et donc plus voudra
que le pays sorte d'une situation de
crise aiguë plus on devra accompagner
cette sortie de crise aiguë d'une
capacité à équiper
sur ce sujet je n'ai mon tempérament
n'est jamais de m'exonérer de quoi que
ce soit mais j'ai un principe simple
quand on mène une bataille on doit être
uni pour la gagner et je pense que
toutes celles et ceux qui cherchent déjà
à faire des procès alors que nous
n'avons pas gagné la guerre sont
irresponsables
le temps viendra de la responsabilité ce
temps viendra
et il est légitime et démocratique et à
ce moment là la transparence complète
devra être faite mais j'appelle d'abord
à la dignité et à l'esprit de
responsabilité celles et ceux qui
construisent des certitudes avec les
connaissances d'aujourd'hui quand ça
n'était pas celle d'hier
vous savez je pourrai retrouver les
paroles de toutes celles et ceux qui
vous explique les grandes difficultés
qui quelques jours avant mon premier la
première allocution de 12 mars expliqué
qu' il serait indigne de reporter les
élections municipales qui tout ça est
une mise en scène du gouvernement et va
trop loin
tout le monde a appris et nous apprenons
tous avec beaucoup d'humilité parce que
cette pandémie est inédite
donc il faut avoir de l'humilité tous
ceux qui agissent
c'est ce que je demande au gouvernement
que je m'appliquais moi même ceux qui
comme nantes donc l'humilité est de mise
et ne ne revoyons pas les semaines
passées à l'aune des connaissances
d'aujourd'hui elles ont quasiment
changer chaque jour et vous le savez
bien vous qui informés et on apprend
chaque jour de cette crise partout dans
le monde
ensuite c'est un principe de méthode
quand on mène un combat on doit tous
être unis
donc moi je crois à l'unité j'appelle
l'ensemble des françaises et des
français à cette unité
elle est indispensable pour gagner cette
bataille ensuite viendra le temps des
responsabilités et on regardera tous et
tout ce qu'on pouvait mieux faire ce
qu'on aurait pu mieux faire et on devra
le faire là aussi avec un principe de
justice à l'égard de tous les choix
passé quel que soit d'ailleurs
responsables politiques parce qu'on peut
pas demander à des gens d'avoir pris des
décisions il ya cinq ou dix ans qui ne
pouvait pas anticiper ce qu'on vient de
vivre
donc faut aussi avoir dirait un esprit
de justice à l'égard de tous et tout
quand on vit quelque chose qui est
inédit peut pas demander aux gens
d'avoir prévu il ya dix ans
donc j'essaie d'appliquer aux autres que
je m'applique à moi même mais le temps
en tout cas et pas aujourd'hui à sa voix
a assigné les responsabilités le temps
il est à s'unir à multiplier les
solidarités a multiplié les innovations
on voit d'ailleurs partout dans le pays
et à se tenir les coudes pour terrasser
ce virus c'est ça ce que j'attends de
nous ensuite on verra
merci à vous courage et merci à toutes
et tous de nous avoir accueillis y est
d'être au combat merci